two things happened i was faster and it
cost me less
i was faster because when opus one or
chateau lafitte or
don perrione's new vintage came out i
would email it
the day it came in and i would get the
sale a month later
those individuals would get the catalog
from my competitors
saying the new don perry owns here so i
was winning on speed but also
cost and then finally the tipping point
was google adwords
i was smart enough to realize google was
a big platform
they launched the adwords product and
literally on the day they launched the
adwords product i started buying wine
terms
at first wine bordeaux merlot champagne
later i had to pick you know you have to
get smarter because people started
figuring it out but i had about a year
there where i was paying 5 cents and
then it became 10 cents
for every wine term you can imagine and
acquiring customers for nothing
sometimes 20 30 cents to get customers
active customers which is insane
so that became about a couple years ago
i realized what i've been talking about
was
underpriced attention meaning the reason
i'm so passionate about linkedin now
but didn't say a word about it six years
ago is
the organic reach on a linkedin post for
a business right now
is meaningful because linkedin has so
much attention on it
yet not as much content and ads on it
yet
this is what always happens you're able
to get some organic reach
when you post to me that is the holy
grail of marketing when you're getting
people to know about your business or
you
and it costs you less aka either zero on
organic reach
or why facebook became so big
when you can spend 50 dollars and get
people to see it
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
hi everyone thanks for joining us this
afternoon uh we're delighted to be
hosting gary vaynerchuk for the next
hour
we will be having q a at the end so
please make sure you get your questions
in the right hand corner so we can get
to them
um so this guy needs no introduction
uh gary is the chairman of vaynerx uh
the active ceo of vaynermedia ceo of
vaynersports
serial entrepreneur uh prolific angel
investor and
five times new york bestseller so
welcome gary
thank you so much emma how are you i'm
good how are you keeping
i'm keeping uh it's gonna i think all of
us
will very much struggle to ever forget
2020
uh and i um and i'm really excited to be
here i just want to say hello to
everybody
uh on the linkedin side uh a platform
i'm extremely fond of and
i've had the luxury of doing events in
in america and other parts and
big special shout out to to niall uh
who uh worked with me at vayner for many
many many years who i know is having a
fantastic career in linkedin and i've
not been doing a whole lot of these
because i've been really in operations
mode
but when he asked i knew i had to say
yes so i'm really glad to be here with
you
oh it's great thanks so much and i know
we've loaded the linkedin attendees who
are so excited to get your insight and
perspective on the industry so um
we'll get we'll dive in with some
questions but the first thing i have to
ask you in
through linkedin style and it wouldn't
be a linkedin event without it is
can you tell us what's not on your
linkedin profile
what's not on my linkedin so you know
when you're a prolific entrepreneur
you you end up
forgetting some of the things you're
even doing so
i've had for example what's not on my
linkedin profile in the last 36 months
i've had two companies that i've
co-founded or founded
empathy wines which was a direct to
consumer wine brand and resi
which was a restaurant app
pos system for restaurants and on the
consumer side demand side
have substantial exits rezzy sold for
hefty nine figures to amex
and empathy i just sold about a month
and a half ago to consolation brands the
biggest
wine company in the world for almost 100
million dollar exit
and neither of those two substantial
business wins
are on my linkedin profile though i
would say probably you know a lot of
times when people see me
they think of me as a motivational
speaker as a content creator and a lot
of times if i'm being very transparent
you know a part of me is upset by that
because i have so much pride in the fact
that
you know between building my dad's
business building vayner
rezzy empathy uh my angel investments
i have a substantial actual career
that's overshadowed by my
prolific content creation and sometimes
that's my own fault in doing because
here i have these big business wins and
i'm not i'm not even
listing them on my linkedin account so
i'm as soon as i'm hanging up here i'm
going to get to work and make sure it
gets up
you should you should they're they're
amazing achievements and you you talk
about that your your personal brand i
mean
there's no doubt about it you've been a
pioneer in the practice of
of building a personal brand how do you
feel it's contributed to your
to your success you know
when you put yourself out there as a
human being your
your there's no question to me that
there's an incredible amount of benefits
you know i started an agency
an advertising agency 11 years ago and
really nine years ago because the first
two years i was
quite passive my younger brother really
held it down because i was still running
my dad's business and it was actually
what really threw me off was i wrote my
first book crush it and that became
a new york times bestseller and a big
one and
that kind of got me you know pulled into
speaking and other things and i wanted
to take advantage of that so
but i started this business coming from
being a wine merchant in new jersey
so it was really my personal brand
the book the speeches the content that
even gave us a chance
to have those first conversations with a
pepsi
with a campbell's with a ge
and it was built on that back because
otherwise there was no
knowledge there was no rationale for the
biggest companies in the world to take a
meeting with us
started by a wine merchant and a kid
that came out of college
so it's contributed in the start of
vayner for sure media
it's contributed in the fact that mark
zuckerberg
allowed me to invest in his company
because of my personal brand
you know not because of anything else i
was just again
a wine merchant and now twitter and
facebook and tumblr david carp
you know blaine cook at twitter these
humans
were interested in me because of the
content i was putting out on the
internet
and it became the gateway the
the ticket to let me into different
places in my life
so it's been a it's been a huge door
opener
people you're on the in when you put out
content to the world what happens next
is people reach out to you
so you know whether it's dwayne the rock
johnson or whether
it's johnson and johnson i have had
people reach out to me instead of me
having to reach out to them because i've
created brand
and that's been incredibly powerful to
my career
the the downside is you have to live and
die by
your personality so i am a scrappy
immigrant kid that grew up in
middle class new jersey and so that has
meant
that my content has cursing in it which
you know so i've just told you some nice
things i know for fact
that we were on the verge of getting a
multi-million dollar contract from a
fortune 50 company
and a board member saw linked linkedin
actually this is funny to tell you guys
saw a linkedin video
where i was crass in my language not in
what i was talking about
and literally sent an email to the ceo
which the ceo then sent an email to the
division leader
that basically eliminated our agency
from being able to do work
because she was unhappy with that and
and and i'm competitive and i'm and i'm
um
an over-the-top personality so there's
definitely been
um there's definitely been some losses
along the way
but you you kind of kind of live your
life in knowing that
there's some pluses and minuses to it
you know when you put yourself out there
you've allowed people to make judgment
of you
and though 98 of the comments on every
linkedin post that i put out
are incredibly positive there's no
question that there's two percent of
well this guy's a charlatan he actually
doesn't know anything
um and you know when you're a human
being
no matter how thick your skin is no
matter how much success you have
it never feels nice to have somebody
call you names or
or degrade you and so you know it's a
process
that is not for everyone but i do
believe
net-net has more positive than negative
impacts yeah that's really interesting
it's you know the reason it's
interesting and i appreciate you kind of
the way that processed for you and i
hope for the people that are watching
is is it's the reason most people don't
do it emma
the reason most people don't put out
content like to me again
um i you know what's fun about living my
life i put out all my content
uh all the time so i think everybody
here knows that i'm not pandering to the
linkedin
audience right now i have been an
incredibly big advocate about linkedin
content for the last five years
it's it's a game changer for people's
professional careers
linkedin's organic reach is remarkable
best in the world
along with tick tock meaning anybody
here gavin
you uh jennifer shaw sweet christopher
glenn anybody here
tomorrow can make their first video on
their linkedin account
about something maybe different and
start the process of having
more people know about them but the
reason most people don't
is they can't deal with the negative
pushback
and that is um unfortunate and that's
why i've spent a lot of time with my
content talking about self-esteem
and self-worth and self-love and
patience and
all the things that are needed and
required to actually have a chance to be
successful
at content creation it's it's much more
of a
of a mental game than it is a creative
what do i post it's can i deal with the
ramifications of posting
of course yeah you talk about how you're
how you're using linkedin now like how
have you seen linkedin
evolve as a platform and how are you
using it now versus
say a couple of years ago and
potentially how are your teams using it
as well for business development
you know i don't know i i would argue
and i give facebook an incredible amount
of credit for their evolution over the
last 15 years but i would still say
that out of all the platforms in the
world the one that has gone through the
most significant
transformation is linkedin here's why it
started off
truly as a utility it there was no part
of linkedin
seven years ago that made people think
content creation
social i mean people refer to linkedin
as a social network
now in certain pockets of the industry
so um
you know six years ago i could go an
entire year without going to my linkedin
because i was an entrepreneur
i wasn't looking for jobs and you know
the end
pretty much now i would argue that when
i have a business objective
it's the first place i think about um
and so
you know it's also evolved into
vaynermedia we
um produce an enormous amount of broad
content
with other cmos not even our own clients
we do we're doing something called
marketing for the now right now which is
a two hour free
seminar once every 10 days where we
interview
a bunch of the thought leaders in the
business world and i would argue that 50
of the reason we do it is just to give
us post-production creative for our
vaynermedia linkedin
because that brings awareness from other
marketers about our agency
and so so it has become a massive force
and is also a big part of our playbook
as an agency provider
we we have become very aggressive going
after b2b
clients because we think instead of
doing print ads in the b2b magazine
or buying million dollar booths at
conferences that linkedin content
strategy
is the single best strategy for every
b2b marketer
and and now even scarier last night i
was talking to a
food cpg company and during the meeting
i said look i think linkedin is
something you need to think about i
think linkedin is acting like facebook
did seven years ago
and i know how you're thinking about it
senior marketer who's not in the
trenches
but i would tell you that if you put out
recipe content
on linkedin right now it will do
extremely well
and um and and you should be looking at
this platform a different way and so i
think
i think people are starting to kind of
quote unquote get it that there's
something really going on
here you talk about this
marketing for now initiative that you're
running how do you see like with
everything that's happened this year and
a pandemic how do you see recovery
taking shape for marketeers how do you
see them coming out of this
what's your perspective on it my
perspective is that the global economy
is in much worse shape than anyone's
really talking about
because everyone's printed money you
know we've got
a lot of conflict you've got nuances of
nationalism sprinting
everywhere around the world led by
america and china
and and i think you know i would argue
that first of all i have no clue because
we're not out of it right you know
what's really difficult about that
question uh and
when i'm asked it is look first you know
geopolitical and global economic
variables have to play out and that's a
little bit above my pay grade
you know i haven't done that homework
but what i can tell you is
it's very clear to me that the common
sense fundamentals are in a very
vulnerable spot
and you have a major election in the u.s
and you have some pretty
aggressive things going around the world
you have conflict in my former
you know birthplace of belarus where
they're trying to overthrow a dictator
you've got real stuff going on and so i
think that
i think that people are a little naive
in thinking well i think the world has
had a very good run
because you know if you think about it
economically outside of the recession
the global recession of 2008 the
reality is is that the world has had a
fairly good run
economically over the last 40 years and
i think that that has made us very soft
and very naive to what could happen now
i'm not predicting doomsday or
depressions or great recessions but i
will say that
um we are so far away from understanding
recovery because recovery is a
fascinating thing
this is not like a war or a recession
where
you've already understood the dynamics
one could argue
that you will never see human beings
again at an airport
not not wearing a mask let's just say
that's true emma
if that's true just on that
just on everything went back to normal
except
when every human travels they wear mess
just that
heavily impacts a lot of businesses
gravel the food and beverage businesses
that rely
on you know the ecosystems of global
airports
you know there's just a call duty-free
shot like
there's just that look and by the way
all of us know that that's not the case
there'll be many many more ramifications
of this
so not to mention something that i don't
think people remember about you know in
america i talked to a lot of executives
about remember 911
it was devastating and then for the next
five years
any time anything happened with a plane
or this you were gun shy i mean
i expect every human being for the next
five years
to overreact to another human being
sneezing
in any situation what does that mean
just think about that does that mean
that events
and restaurants have a three percent
decline
let's just say three percent emma you
know restaurants work on such low margin
that if they just lose three to five
percent of their business
because the most extreme of us
are scared post corona and really kind
of just
don't leave the house anymore period or
far
less often if you were somebody who went
out to eat 28 times a year you're down
to three
if that's the case for some businesses
they can't recover with that five
percent loss that was all their profit
and so i i think the ramifications are
substantial
on the flip side there's a lot of
businesses that will explode
every direct to consumer business on the
internet
is going to grow with that transition so
i think i think there's still a lot
unknown
um as a matter of fact this morning back
to you know
uh the uk market you know this morning i
woke up to
boris johnson saying that they're gonna
take the groups
that gatherings down from 30 to six
that's a step backwards to recovery
right that doesn't mean you know and i
and i think that this is going to go on
for a little while and i don't think
people are really
i don't think most people realize that
it's going to be next summer
if everything goes remarkably well
to where you kind of might start seeing
the first toe in the water back to
normalcy that's a long time that's not i
remember when this all
happened i thought oh my god we're gonna
close the offices for two weeks
that's crazy it's gonna end up being
closer to two years than two weeks so i
think that
i think it's unprecedented times and and
i think it's way early to figure out
what happens but what i can tell you is
for me and this is just i would call
this luck
for me the fact that everything in my
mind has been about
video streaming and the cell phone and
you know
lack of friction internet only the real
world is secondary nice
important but it's secondary to this
world
you know that has put me in a position
as a communicator
and as a business operator in a better
spot than some businesses
because i bet on the internet and the
internet is the real winner
of this you know of this
reality i mean i would very likely be
doing this
in person with you emma the next time i
was in the region
now i'll be able to do it three times
with you
and i'm sitting in my apartment right
now and so you know
i mean i can tell you right now i think
it takes generations for the airline and
travel industry to recover from this
because even when everybody in five
years is back to normal
i'm still gonna debate do i need to go
to san francisco today
for this meeting or can i do this on
zoom or hangouts or blue jeans
and the answer six out of ten times is i
can do it on blue jeans
i mean it's it's the it's the changes
that are going to happen for all these
industries your name so some are going
to explode and
some are going to be devastated for
years to come i guess it's
you know a sales people ourselves what
kind of advice would you have for us
approaching
these marketeers these cmos or ceos
whether they're of
advertising agencies like yourselves or
if they're direct with clients what
advice would you would you give us
let me go very narrow with this answer
let's
make pretend the pandemic didn't even
happen i would tell everybody here
to have more pride in the product you're
selling
you know i have the unfortunate thing
where i get to do fireside chats with
companies that i think are going through
challenges and because i'm
you know this is being recorded i want
to be historically correct
so i'm a nice person but i don't want to
say something i don't believe
so sometimes when that question is asked
i get into
hey can i speak to the engineers and the
product people because your product's
not very good right now
and who cares if you're a good salesman
you're not going to have good lifetime
value
i think i have the great fortune to have
the reverse conversation right now with
everybody on this call
i would tell you the number one thing
that i would tell everybody here is to
have
way more pride in what you're selling i
know
because i'm very close to the world that
most brands
b2b included have not accepted the
incredible power that linkedin is as
a content and marketing engine it is
everyone's job on this call
to actually break through to agencies
and to brands and i think that most of
you will be too passive
i think you need to go in with way more
conviction way more
audacity because you actually do have
one of the best tools
in marketing at your fingertips and i
know the world doesn't know it
so you need to cross all your t's and
eyes with the examples but most of all
you need to go into those rooms on the
borderline of audacious because you're
selling one of the best products
and i know that's not the tone and tenor
because what happens is when
something's not accepted by the world
most sales people
come in too passive and my career has
been
when i know i have the right thing when
it's right
for the customer then if i'm going to
somebody in between the humans that use
it
and the cost and and like if there's a
decision maker aka
the ceo of wyden and kennedy or or or
the cmo of cadbury
if that person's in between that company
doing it with linkedin
and the people that actually consume it
the actual people in the feed of
linkedin
well and i know linkedin is right well
i'm being very aggressive
in my conviction i'm very convicted and
i think
and i think clients and agencies need to
hear that from a salesperson
because if they're skeptical and you
come in too passive
you're too far away now to move them
and so as a salesperson i've only sold
things i believe in
because i don't know how to be a
salesperson when i don't because it
requires too much conviction to get
somebody on board
listen this is a real pleasure and joy
for me i
i hope everybody on this call really
realizes how strong the product is right
now
the organic reach is remarkable and the
targeting
is remarkable because it's not
replicated anywhere else in the world i
cannot get
to that many business decision makers
all with the same title
on their job description anywhere else
in the world that is the ultimate weapon
and the same way that it took facebook a
half a decade to get its feet under them
to really go out there and get the
dollars i think that we're
we're i'm hoping for your sake i mean to
me in a weird way
to me the longer people don't know that
linkedin is this strong
is better for vayner and me because i'm
picking up more organic reach
but but for the context of what i was
invited to
speak here this is a rare opportunity
for me to flex
on your behalf this is a very great era
for
linkedin marketing and um and i hope
that you're communicating that to your
clients
thank you for that feedback um we were
talking there about organic reach
and you talk quite a bit about
underpriced attention
can you talk to me a little bit what you
mean by underpriced attention and how
can linkedin lean into that
oh underpriced attention i've come to
realize is really my religion
you know i built my dad's business from
a 3.8 million dollar business to a 65
million
business in seven years and i had no
money and the
reason i was able to do that was three
things one
i realized that having a website was
going to be important so i built a
website and that alone was a big deal
this is 1996. number two
a couple a year later i realized email
was a big deal
and this was the great gift of my career
email
ended up being a killer app for selling
stuff and it was
free so my competitors were printing
catalogs
with wine in it and shipping it which
cost them a lot of money to make the
catalog and a lot of money in postage
i was gathering people's emails every
time they came into the store i
literally emma would not let somebody
leave my dad's store without giving me
their email
and i think you can tell my tenacity and
i was a youngster i was real hungry then
so
you know and through that two things
happened i was faster and it cost me
less
i was faster because when opus one or
chateau lafitte or
dom perry owns new vintage came out i
would email it the day it came in
and i would get the sale a month later
those individuals would get the catalog
from my competitors
saying the new don perry owns here so i
was winning on speed but also cost
and then finally the tipping point was
google adwords
i was smart enough to realize google was
a big platform
they launched the adwords product and
literally on the day they launched the
adwords product i started buying wine
terms
at first wine bordeaux merlot champagne
later i had to pick you know you have to
get smarter because people started
figuring
it out but i had about a year there
where i was paying
five cents and then it became 10 cents
for every wine term you can imagine
and acquiring customers for nothing
sometimes
20 30 cents to get customers active
customers which is insane
so that became about a couple years ago
i realized what i've been talking about
was underpriced attention
meaning the reason i'm so passionate
about linkedin now
but didn't say a word about it six years
ago is
the organic reach on a linkedin post for
a business right now is meaningful
because linkedin has so much attention
on it
yet not as much content and ads on it
yet this is what always happens you're
able to get some organic reach
when you post to me that is the holy
grail of marketing when you're getting
people to know about your business or
you
and it costs you less aka either zero on
organic reach
or why facebook became so big
when you can spend fifty dollars and get
people to see it
one of my issues with linkedin has been
that there's a floor
on the cpm on the cost there's a two
dollar floor not a five cent floor
so i want to take advantage of you know
the long tail of targeting so
every time i see my linkedin
counterparts in the us
working with my media it's funny it's
like an ongoing joke because i'm
i think you can tell by the tone i've
had here i'm such a fan of linkedin but
in one very specific place and i
understand why you do it because it's a
lack of inventory so it allows you to
create a floor i understand
but i still like to razz and every time
i walk by a meeting with my media team
and the linkedin team i pop my head in
them like have you lowered the floor and
it's
become almost this like little mean joke
but um that's how i see it which is
for certain things i do not believe to
paying two dollars per cpm is the right
thing and that's why we are very
tactical on linkedin
in other arenas paying 70
cpms is the right thing and we're only
paying 13
because there's not that much spend
against that narrow thing
and that's that would be an example of
me saying wow linkedin's remarkable i'm
only paying 13
cpms here to reach this executive class
that's an incredible deal for this
company i'd have to pay
and then when you amortize conversion i
might be paying 13
cpms but it might cost me a thousand
dollars to get a customer
whereas it will cost me way more on
facebook or twitter
or youtube to get that same customer
because
linkedin has so much data around people
and their professional career
that's why linkedin is an underpriced
medium for me
it's media product it's ad product has
the capabilities of being better
than anything else in the world on very
specific
planning and then on top of that it also
has
organic reach that i don't see from
anywhere besides
tick tock right now and obviously very
two very different audiences
so underpriced attention to me is things
like the super bowl in america cost six
million dollars
and i think it's unbelievably
underpriced because
a hundred million people will watch your
commercial meanwhile
i think a regular commercial on the
telly is
overpriced because there's assumptions
about
grps and nielsen ratings that i just
know are not true
in common sense facebook
organic used to be the greatest thing in
the world it doesn't even exist anymore
it's an ad product running the ads on
facebook as we do and we
took tune of hundreds of millions of
dollars there's a lot of ways to make it
underpriced it's by doing
contextual creative at scale and doing
80 different
media spends instead of one there's ways
to make it overpriced on linkedin
youtube facebook where you just do one
video
and you just try to reach everybody 18
to 55. so
i spend my life being religious around
where's the nook and cranny that allows
me to pay five cents
that is really worth 20 cents on
business
in a minefield where there's a lot of
places you can spend 20 cents
and only get five cents value that's
what i mean by underpriced attention
i can't hear you emma oh sorry can you
hear me now you got better i can't yes
it is
um no i just say that that was great
thank you so i mean
you obviously you've you know over the
years you've seen how all the different
social platforms have evolved you've
definitely been
at the cutting edge what do you believe
is the next big thing for social or
what's coming down the track what do you
think is the next big thing
you know it's funny i uh i don't um
i don't predict what i'm really great at
emma
is being the fastest mover when it's
become obvious
so you know what i've had a great career
on
is when linkedin made that switch i was
there right away
you know i was one of those first
hundred influencers of that first
hundred influencers
i produced the most content you know and
so
uh when musically the predecessor to
tock had some momentum even though it
looked like it was just 12 year old
girls
i was in there making content so
you know i don't know what the next tick
tock or facebook or linkedin
you know linkedin and tick tock are a
lot of fun for me because they're the
two leaders of organic
which is always the thing i talk about
because a lot of people follow me have
no money
and so when you have no money you need
organic what's fun about tick tock and
linkedin is
tick tock is the newest of a line of
snapchat
facebook twitter a true social network
for the youth
that's growing linkedin's a great one
for my thesis of not predicting i would
have never predicted
linkedin as the next content place
linkedin is a story of a pivot or not a
pivot
a a very smart addition
to a ongoing platform what that means is
one could argue that youtube tomorrow
can say wait a minute
why don't we just add a stream of
content that doesn't have to be video
and they might become a more meaningful
social network
you could you would probably more
logically argue that that would be a
distraction and that's why they haven't
done it
right now there's two you know
incredible you know
16 year olds in in scotland
who might be making the next great app
that's not something i could know about
i'm not nostradamus
but i can promise you that if that app
gets traction
sustained traction because you do see a
lot of apps have a good week
or a good month or a good day uh
and and there's an unbelievable amount
of names peach and
and and vine even had a very nice run
until it was bought social cam
clerk friendster myspace
you've got these things that have one
week even sometimes
three year runs i'm not a predictor
but i'm a practitioner of the moment
of the apps that are winning
brilliant i mean we look at you know you
you look at social as a whole and if we
if we pivot now more to vayner x you
know it's an absolute
juggernaut how did you navigate the
landscape
a landscape dominated by global holding
company
patience you know it's we're 10 years in
we're still
a 200 million dollar revenue holding bow
which is
peanuts peanuts compared to the
publicists and omnicoms and things that
nature
but we're emerging and we're emerging
because of underpriced attention what i
mean by that is
in the same way that i do underpriced
attention as a businessman
i look for opportunities that people
don't see
and we became the best in the world no
question
and i'm proud to say this and i know it
sounds audacious but it is very clear to
me
that there is no agency in the world
that is better at
understanding how to make content and
run media
across the 15 apps that dominate the
mobile phone
linkedin youtube facebook twitter and i
think people are starting to realize
wait a minute that is where brand is
being built that is not where
you're just doing lower funnel
conversion that's actually where brand
is being built
and brand is the game and as the biggest
companies in the world say oh my god i
don't want a tv first approach
i want a social burst approach that
makes me find what i should put on tv
we become you know we've got a loud
leader
who's got a decade of being historically
correct
on the content that he's put out which
gives enormous amount of confidence to
these decision makers
and not to mention the other thing that
i didn't think of because you don't
think about being old when you're young
but you know in a decade or two here
the majority of cmos that are going to
be making the decisions
grew up on my content and my books
and so just you know from a brand
standpoint and we're starting to feel it
you know there's been a couple of
moments here in the last year i'm like
wait a minute this is cool the person
that actually made that decision
they decided this was right in
university when they were reading my
book in class
like we don't like that was a weird
pitch they were saying
my words to me we didn't even have to
convince them so as the decision maker
evolves
um you know what we have the benefit of
is that
what we've been focused on actually
became true
most of the marketing world dismissed
and continues to be frank
dismisses social media or content on
these platforms as a
nice to have i view it as the singular
source of oxygen for businesses going
forward
you know just it's it you know you can't
worry about anything
at you have to start with being an
incredible content producer
to the relevant cohorts and segments in
these channels
and then you can worry about putting
your logo on a
football you know jersey for the premier
league or
running an ad on telly or or doing
outdoor billboards
in the subway systems and because you've
already figured out the right answer
in these channels at very low cost uh so
we'll see but i i've navigated it by
being
more right about where the world was
going
and it's not because i'm smarter it's
because the holding companies
are attached to where the money is right
now
they're not gonna they're gonna sell
commercials and
because that's where the money is now
because they're publicly traded and they
have to make revenue every quarter
i'm building something in perpetuity
which has allowed me to
play a different game and we're starting
to feel the benefits of that
i'm just gonna pivot slightly just i'm
i'm conscious of time and there's
there's just one
kind of area i'd love to get your your
perspective obviously talk about the
year we've had
i'd love to to hear how you have managed
your
physical and mental well-being during
the pandemic you know we were only
looking at two weeks of offices being
closed down
and we ended up going into weeks and
then months so i'd love to get
how you manage your physical and and
mental well-being and how can we
kind of create a culture of getting
people to prioritize this for themselves
you know for me um it's been about
choices it's recognizing early on that
this was not going to be a one day thing
and being self-aware this is a
self-awareness game right to me
i know that i do my best
when i am optimistic and when my
perspective is proper
so i went into a tunnel vision of hey
this is a bummer
but but in the 1940s people were running
very successful companies and then the
nazis invaded
so you know this stinks but in the
history of time there's been tougher
times and for me that always works
for me to lean into gratitude and into
worst case scenario that works for my
psyche
uh i also uh have
had enough success in my career that six
years ago i was able to afford a
full-time trainer
just for me and and that is how i got my
health
into a much better place and so i knew
that
by not him babysitting me that i was
vulnerable so i had a very quick call
with him early on and said hey we're
going to train virtually
on zoom you're going to watch me go on
the scale every day so i don't lose my
way
um and so i i kind of attacked
a strategy early on from a physical and
mental place
and i think everybody here needs to do
the same if you know that you
binge eat when you're stressed and you
don't want to put on 30 pounds during
covid
you need to first acknowledge that truth
and then try to find a system that works
for you whether that's
asking your spouse to hold you
accountable whether that's creating a
facebook group
whether that's putting out content and
holding yourself accountable
whether that's throwing out all the food
that's you know
my mom and i are very similar we'll eat
literally anything in front of us
so if it's a candy bar or if it's green
beans it's all the same we're just
we call ourselves lawnmowers i have
successfully
taken all bad food out of my house my
mom continues to not
and thus he's had a different experience
in covid than i have had
you know i i think it's self-awareness
and
but then also not over judging yourself
emma i think the reason people struggle
is they beat themselves up
and uh and i'd like everybody to have a
little more compassion and sympathy for
themselves
during this time aka if you did gain 15
pounds in this
year it's okay when we get back to
normal and you can go and do what works
for you
in the next year you'll lose that and so
enjoy the crack you know the candy
while you can so i i think it's a
balance of strategy
and self-love
really great advice there as well i
think it's it's it's been a tough year
for people so that's that's really great
to hear
yeah it's been a very challenging year
and i think
a couple things one why should we
as humans live lives during all easy
times when our grandparents great
grandparents great great grandparents
didn't
so i think one the first thing everyone
has to do is get off
get over their own audacity and
entitlement
to like this great you know it's not the
way it actually works
you have both sides of the coin i think
once you get over that
if you don't beat yourself up or not you
know a lot of people are beating
themselves up because they didn't save
money even though
they knew it was the right thing to do
they didn't because they wanted to live
a certain lifestyle and now they
are in a pickle what many will do in
that scenario is start to really be
upset with themselves
you should have a self reflection moment
but you can't go into a time machine and
change the fact that you went on
vacations you couldn't afford and buy
clothes you couldn't afford
so you're not gonna be able to do that
what you can do is make a commitment to
yourself to going forward
acting in a different way and i think
you know i hope that people learn
about themselves during this time
hey we're nearly ready for q a but i
just wanted to ask you just one question
well what is the question that you're
never asked in these discussions that
you wish you were
asked you know i think i think
you know i think this is a very
interesting answer i
when i sign up for these i'm 100
focused on bringing value to the
audience so i don't have any wishes on
questions
i the only question i'm i wish people
ask is
if they actually have a question but
they're scared to ask it because they
think it would offend me
or i wouldn't know the answer who knows
what would be the rationale
i'm here to service in this setting
so i don't have any real feelings
towards a question i want to be asked
i just want to answer the question that
everybody wants to be asked
to be honest look with that what we'll
do is we're actually going to bring
niall back on screen because he thought
it'd be great to have him involved
and and he's been moderating the q a so
now i'm going to let you take over the
questions thank you
hi hey gary hey again
to see your friend it's always great
it's been a while
listen we've got some awesome questions
through for you across a few different
channels
um so we should be able to get through
them in about 13 minutes
oh and i'll just get started here um the
first question comes in
from um someone on my team aaron mciver
uh and it's about sports cards
i i think you might end about um it's
around really about the
with the rise of online platforms do you
uh such as panini blockchain
um do you see that the sports card
industry will become predominantly a
virtual offering in the future
and if so how will this impact trading
value of existing
physical cards i don't think so
at least in let's say the next half
century um do i think something can lose
its value as a physical item
in all shapes and form of course i do i
just think it's too early
for like blockchain is an unbelievable
technology and i think we'll have
incredible ramifications
on society over the next century
but do i think that everything gets
tokenized as quickly as a lot of
blockchain enthusiasts
think the answer is no and i and the
reason i say that is
look how far along we are in the last
half decade i mean
blockchain has been very uh
prominent for the last half decade and
we still don't have
anywhere close to the amount of
innovation on it
that i think many of us thought could be
the case
five years ago and so i think that
the tokenization of sports cards and art
and many other things will happen
i think that there'll be some moments of
things popping
um kind of similar to the way that
augmented reality technology is
incredibly strong
right now in the world yet we've only
had pokemon go be a real phenomenon in
the ar
world so do i think now that
something can come along and get
tokenized and do really well
um yes but you know for example when you
know this about me now i don't talk
about or do things that i don't believe
in if i thought
that trading cards and football stickers
which would be more european
would lose its value i wouldn't be
buying moombape
you know rookie cards for five thousand
dollars a piece
why to watch it go down in value so i i
don't think in the short term
there's going to be that level of
traction i think i think people
underestimate human behavior here's what
i mean by that
online dating in the in the mid 90s i
told all my friends
that all of them would be doing online
dating if they didn't get married before
online dating
and when i tell you everybody made fun
of me for saying that they made fun of
me because
at the time in 1996 online dating
was very creepy and was really when you
thought about online dating
the image you thought about was a 600
pound guy in his mom's basement
well now as we all know online dating is
foundational
to all youth all everyone for that
matter
i feel the same way about physical
things
i think that people think everything's
going to go on blockchain
and it will but even though online
dating
is massive across the world there is a
stunning amount of people
who do not do it and still go to the pub
or get introduced to their sister and i
think niall that's what will happen in
40 years with sports cards and other
tangible goods
i think there'll be a absolute world of
tokenization and blockchain
but i don't think that will take away
from people and i would argue
that it might even enhance the value of
the most rare
physical items you know it's it's what
we see now
we've already seen in our young lives
everybody here the growth
and creation of social networks the
slow but steady curve of people spending
time on it
and now the apex moments of it so much
so
that kids predominantly in their teens
are taking week or month breaks
from it because they're the counter
culture
to it much like the rise of blockchain
will actually create tokenization of
items
and then you'll see people want to own
the physical
card because everything went digital no
different than hipsters in brooklyn
wanting to own pagers and flip phones
instead of the iphone
the human race likes to swing pendulums
and over the next century will swing to
the digitalization of physical goods
only to then be countered with people
going backwards into physical goods
just like what's happening with food
habits i hope everybody understands
what's happening with food
in the world people are starting to eat
clean
the way that people ate 150 years ago
we then had the rise of modern food and
business and technology
create all the things we known and now
people are trying to go back to just
ingredients and clean eating
so that's just how humans work
[Music]
awesome thanks gary um next question
uh for anyone i'm going through the the
q a
in liked first
um you mentioned the key to success is
not really caring too much about what
other people think
how do you get yourself into the mindset
to be able to kick through any doors
um or people who have said you can't do
something this is from
steve o'brien
you know steve i think for me it was a
journey
of losing a lot as a child you know i
was an immigrant i didn't speak the
language so it was hard for me to
you know make friends when i first got
to america then i was a bad student
so all my teachers said no you're a
failure bad
push against i wasn't you know after
about third or fourth grade
i it was clear to me that i was not
remarkable at sports
so there wasn't that thing that a lot of
kids rely on
so i basically lived the life with a lot
of adversity and a lot of know
you know my parents didn't buy me things
mom i want nintendo no
you know like my life was about no and
so
it was very easy once i became an adult
to be comfortable in no
for a lot of you my children included
know was you were in the business of yes
you know and
in that became the vulnerability because
no seems scary
foreign so i think the biggest way for
you
or anybody else at a more advanced stage
of not being a child anymore
is getting into the practice of losing
and doing
knows trying things that are hard for
you
doing things that require no you
people need to have a relationship with
no
and that is only something that
either you are serendipitously growing
up with
and or something that you manufacture
for yourself when you get older by
putting yourself in
uncomfortable positions so that you
become more comfortable with
rejection
it's ironic you ask that question
literally my instagram post
that i snuck in while i was doing the
interview with emma as i multitask
you might have saw me looking down at
some point literally
literally this post that i just posted
is that people are too addicted to
positive reinforcement
you're smart you're pretty that's
awesome
once you believe that you become
susceptible to negative
reinforcement so niall the the reason
i'm able to deal with pushback and no is
actually when emma
introduces me and says all those nice
things
i don't believe them i don't know how to
say it
when i hear that i'm a five-time new
york times bestseller
that's funny to me because i failed all
my english and
writing classes when i hear you know
when emma says something like you've
actually made a dent
in this global advertise you know 10 you
know the style you were with us very
early on
that's funny we were like a ragtag group
of 50 people
that just were sitting in an office
right you know this so
for me i don't get high on my
accomplishments which allows me to not
get low
on when i'm dealing with negativity i
just keep it very
zen very in the middle like i'm aware of
what i've
got going on and where it's going and
i'm also aware that i'm 44 years old
which means
i have a lot of time to build on this
and it can end up being in a very crazy
place
not financially on impact i'm
well known at this point and i'm just
starting so
i know that kind of god willing with
health and
all that you know my destiny at some
level is
for some pretty big bridges but that
will never make me think that i'm better
than somebody
or i'm greater than which allows me to
then
deal with the negativity that comes
along with that much
notoriety and uh and i like that i like
that i don't get too high and i don't
get too low
awesome great answer um all right next
question shifting gears ever so slightly
um this is well now real quick because i
think you'll understand this
it also it also lends itself because
it's important
because it's meta it also lends itself
to humility
you know the reason i don't struggle
with other people's feedback is because
i'm actually humble
humble enough that when a former
employee like yourself reaches out to me
and says this is important to me
that even though i do not have time i
have negative time
i i right this minute can live the rest
of my 50 years
and not accomplish everything that is in
front of me right now
yet i have the humility and the empathy
compassion and love to say yes to you
because i'm hoping
it helps you right
so if you can have humility and
generosity
it actually makes you less susceptible
to negativity
that's awesome and i can attest to that
anytime i've emailed you you're
back within the hour it's um it's really
impressive it's incredible
linkedin is huge uh it's a very
important platform for me but there is
0.0 chance i'm doing this talk without
you
and i think that being in that place as
a human
um basically what i'm telling everybody
is no matter what level of success you
have
please remember that you're
insignificant that may sound harsh
it's actually an incredibly liberating
exciting experience
i'm doing a lot out here and i know that
if i die tomorrow
i'll have a couple of hours on social
networks where i get a lot of love where
people maybe will share their favorite
story of me
or you'll write nile on your linkedin he
was always there for me and replied in
an hour
or somebody will share their favorite
clip but but in truth
in 72 hours everybody has to go back to
their normal lives
and outside of a group of 25 to 50
people
that's it and i think if you can live in
that humility
it allows you to deal with the ability
it gets very hard if you believe what i
just said
to get two down when anonymous anonymous
anonymous
leaves a comment on your linkedin post
that you suck it's hard to like let that
carry too much weight
when you understand what i just said
let's sneak in two more before i get out
of here all right next question
another one that would be great so next
question
is if you could add one thing to
linkedin streaming what would it be and
why and this is coming from gavin
roberts
it's a little tweak on what you have now
right now live streaming from a mobile
device
is too clunky with third-party
providers i think linkedin is built
for more live experiences but right now
the creator side on the app side is not
strong
and if that can be fixed i think you'll
have even more engagement and more
incredible content linkedin is the place
for meaningful conversations
for ted talk like conversations in live
format
but it's it's just not there yet as a
product
awesome and my teams my child is blowing
up right now from the team saying that
we are invader for us so uh you've uh
you've you've gotten their attention um
okay last question
um before we wrap this up and i let's
say
we'll leave it a good question the
what's the most impressive
brand you've worked with and why
i would say currently it's procter
gamble's olay in the u.s
and and ironically sk2
procter gamble in singapore office um
and because they've given us the freedom
to find the creative right
instead of being right so 99
of marketing behavior today is a
strategist and a creative on an agency
side come up with a hypothesis
try to sell it into a client and then
the client spends all its money
hoping that that messaging was right
which is asinine
what we've been able to do on olay in
the us and sk2 in
asia is produce an enormous amount of
content
across 50 different hypotheses see what
actually is resonating with computers
and then ladder
up the creative i believe that will be
the
creative format of the next century and
i believe that there are very few people
that have the humility
and the lack of fear to go with that
model in corporate
life and i think it's the courage of the
leaders on those pieces of businesses
that have created that opportunity
great and should we wrap it up there and
emma take it away
thanks great to see you there okay
thanks so much for your time today it
was really great we really appreciate we
know how busy you are
and so we really appreciate you taking
the time to chat with us today
and hopefully we'll get to talk to you
again soon bye everyone
i'm very available on linkedin to say
hello so if you had a good time send me
a message i'd love to say hi to some of
you
take care bye hey everybody on youtube
first of all thank you so much so
humbled for your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's plenty more where that came from
feel free to check it out